welcome can you guys all hear me if
you're not from Carnegie Mellon welcome
if you are thank you for coming to this
kickoff event this morning my name is J
Whittaker I'm the director of the Wilton
East Scotts Institute for energy
innovation here at CMU and it is my
distinct honor to kick off energy week
right now I hope that this is the first
of many very interesting sessions we are
starting with the bane we've got some
extraordinary people and in a quick
succession followed by an excellent
keynote address and all that the folks
who I'm about to introduce in series
introduce each other so I'm not going to
spoil or take any of their thunder my
job here today right now is to provide a
bit of context I am the as I say Scott
Institute is our endowed thing here at
CMU to encourage could interconnect and
synergize energy research within the CMU
community there was a tremendous amount
of this kind of work already going on at
CMU prior to the founding of the Scott
Institute and so the job that we have
here is to connect synergize create more
out of the pieces than would have been
without us right
Wilton Scott R is the father of Sherman
Scott who is our the prime named funder
of the Institute and he has created for
us a number of funding mechanisms to
make things real here one of which is
some outreach money that supports energy
week and so we are here today and in the
name of the Scott's to create a lot of
interest
synergy and communication between all
the stakeholders within the University
and outside the university so please one
of our biggest priorities is to have you
all talk amongst yourselves after
enduring sessions if you can if
something happens up here someone says
something that's exciting to you reach
out afterwards we have a lot of
receptions we have time for
communication that is our deal it the
more connections we make the more
interest we bring in everybody wins
so this is sort of a part and parcel
what we're trying to do and I don't have
a whole lot else to say
for the next person who is going to give
the next introduction is the newly
finalized actual president of Carnegie
Mellon University Farnum Jahannam Farnum
was appointed the tenth president of CMU
by its Board of Trustees in March he's
previously the university's provost and
later served as interim president from
July into January he's a nationally
recognized computer scientist
entrepreneur public servant in higher
education leader he brings the CMU
extensive leadership an administrative
expertise not only to advancing research
and education within and across
disciplines but also in translating
research into technologies and practices
that benefit society prior to coming to
CMU Janie and led the National Science
Foundation Directorate for computer and
information science and engineering from
2011 to 2014 and prior to that he was at
the University of Michigan he and I
actually crossed paths there as well
juh Hadean serves as the chair of the
National National Research Council's
computer science and telecommunications
telecommunications board sits on the
Executive Committee of the Council of
competitiveness and is a trustee on the
Dietrich foundation he is also a board
member of the National Center for Women
in information technology the advanced
robotics manufacturing Institute in the
Allegheny conference on community
development among others he has come to
Pittsburgh he has devoted himself he's
thrown himself into all parts of what's
happening here within the university in
the community we are grateful to have
him and so without further ado
thank you very much J for that kind
introduction
you didn't have to remind people that
you and I had a history at Michigan
especially after Monday nights at Mack
Villanova and and Michigan playing but
nonetheless um I'm also grateful to
Steve Colin's team for that picture that
they did the picture looks really good I
was just telling Mike Doyle it's amazing
what technology and Photoshop can do
these days anyway it is so good to be
with you this morning it is my pleasure
on behalf of my colleagues here at
Carnegie Mellon to welcome all of you to
the start of Carnegie Mellon
University's third annual celebration of
energy Week as one of CMU's most
important and high-profile celebrations
energy week brings together thought
leaders from around the world to discuss
the future of energy and the role of
interdisciplinary research and education
in informing this critical area this
morning I'm grateful to be joined by so
many distinguished colleagues and
leaders from within University and also
outside our campus who have contributed
to this work including several of our
prominent elected leaders these
representatives have been particularly
central to CMU's leadership in this area
providing invaluable support for
attracting federal and industry's
research and also advancing new models
of education today we are delighted to
be joined by our senior congressman Mike
Doyle representing Pittsburgh 14th
district also the newly minted US
congressman elect Connor lamb who's
making his first visit to campus since
his recent victory in Pittsburgh's 18th
district
welcome rich Fitzgerald CMU alum an
Allegheny County executive we're happy
to have rich with us and finally another
newly elected official Councilwoman
Erika Strasburg Berger who represents
Pittsburgh eighth district where I
actually live welcome all of you were
happy to have all of you with us thank
you very much for joining us and thank
you so much for your service to our
state to our city and also to our nation
I want to acknowledge also and thank J
Whittaker to trustee professor in the
engineering in energy engineering and
public policy as well as his an
appointment in material science and
engineering for his leadership of the
Scott Institute for energy innovation
which by the way includes more than 150
researchers across our campus I'm also
grateful for his role in planning
districts Jordan ecampus event and also
to Anna SIF kinome know many of you know
Anna who's associate director at the
Institute and the entire Scott Institute
team for this wonderful planning that
they have done for this for this event I
also want to acknowledge our former
president president emeritus Jerry Cohen
who was the founding director of the
Scott Institute for all that he has done
not only for Carnegie Mellon for also
for launching and nurturing the Scott
Institute thank you very much Jerry
please join me in thanking Jay Jerry and
I and all the entire team at the
scotland's
finally this week would not be possible
without our exceptional faculty alumni
and academic leaders including our
Provost who's here and a number of
keynote speakers and panelists who are
contributing to this event again we're
grateful for their contribution it is
entirely fitting that CMU is hosting
this week's important dialogues with our
top-ranked school in engineering and
computer science business and policy
Carnegie Mellon is proud of our
tradition of collaborating with
colleagues across disciplines to
consider complex societal problems in
particular we're at the center of
innovation and policy related to the
future of energy creating sustainable
and affordable energy alternatives
tackling the safety and reliability our
critical infrastructures and so much
more our work in this area has been made
possible by collaborations with the
private sector including companies in
Pittsburgh in the region as well as
universities foundations and community
institutions and Department of Energy's
National Energy Technology laboratories
these tremendous partners have been
instrumental in developing green
building technology transforming
brownfields funding and supporting our
dozens of energy related spinouts and
technology transfers and piloting new
clean energy technologies energy week is
all about bringing these partners
together to adapt as well to adopt as
well as advocate a shared vision for the
economic and technological future of our
city and our region
make no mistake over the coming decades
the world must make fundamental
transformation in how the energy is
produced how its distributed
disseminated as well as how it's used
and consumed at this critical time for
our energy dependent world it's more
important than ever to reaffirm our
commitment to the pursuit of knowledge
and support for long term scientific
discovery and engineering innovations
energy week is just
one of the many campus traditions that
pay tribute to our commitment to
scientific discovery in engineering
innovations and cm roles role in finding
collaborative solutions for energy
challenges through research education
and equally important data-driven
policymaking is is critical we're
particularly delighted to welcome back
several alum number of them you will
meet later on today one particularly mu
is going to be with us later today is
our alumna and mayor of San Juan Puerto
Rico
Carmen Cruz who is going to be in a
conversation with our own Mayor Bill
Peduto later on this afternoon moderated
by our Provost Lori weingartz I'm very
much looking forward to that event later
on this evening there is truly something
for everyone during this event and I
encourage you to explore the energy week
and and especially create new
conversations and new dialogues with
colleagues that are attending this and
now it's my pleasure to introduce a
partner who's been helping to advance
CMU's energy ambitions for more than a
decade and who is a recognized national
leader in energy policy as well as a
member of the House Energy and Commerce
Committee Mike has been at the forefront
of all major energy policy innovations
including advocating for clean fossil
energy and strategies for climate change
he's been a champion for Pittsburgh
position as a world leader in green
building technology in green chemistry
he's also worked hard to ensure that
energy research and innovation
translates into real opportunities and
better quality of life for all
Pittsburghers I can say so much more
about our congressman Mike Doyle from
his leadership in energy research and
innovation to his advocacy for federally
funded research to his leadership of the
robotics area and automation in Congress
for for two decades to his support for
stem initiatives and STEM education we
are truly fortunate to have Mike Doyle
representing Pittsburgh and CMU and were
grateful to Mike for his
service to our nation please join me in
extending my warm welcome to
pittsburgh's one of Pittsburgh's
greatest natural resources Congressman
Mike Doyle Mike for him thank you very
much it's always great to be at CMU and
very pleased to be here to kick off
energy week at CMU you know western
Pennsylvania has been at the epicenter
of our nation's energy advances for more
than 200 years since before the nation's
founding our state's first coal mine was
just across the Mon on Mount Washington
back then it was known as coal hill and
Pennsylvania would go on to produce more
coal than any other state in America the
nation's first oil was found 70 miles
north of here over a century ago and
today we're smack dab in the middle of a
shale revolution and the development of
advanced energy technologies our
region's leadership in energy innovation
is unmatched in the country and now I'm
happy to say we're continuing that
tradition of revolutionary thinking and
action
western Pennsylvania is in many ways a
microcosm of the country's changing
energy landscape we have retiring coal
plants and surrounding communities that
are affected by that job loss we're
witnessing the potential retirement of
nuclear plants we have gas wells and
pipelines and processing plants but you
know we also have energy storage
companies designing batteries utilities
that work with universities to integrate
more distributed generation like wind
and solar and companies that make the
panels and the turbines to harness those
new energy sources we are a cutting-edge
city that is integrating district
heating and cooling and micro grids and
a forward-thinking County pursuing
increasingly sustainable transportation
options and of course we have
groundbreaking research in world-class
universities like CMU incubators
businesses and national labs like the N
eto in South Park
this event bears witness
- that energy transformation the
policymakers business leaders
researchers and energy analysts convene
here by Carnegie Mellon aptly
demonstrate our region's and this
University's influence and leadership in
the energy world the panelists and
speakers that you'll hear from over the
coming days reflected the versity of
interest and opinions in the energy
world and that's a good thing I think
it's far too easy to silo oneself to
interact mostly with those who hold
similar perspectives but such
intellectual isolation usually hinders
real progress
there are many hard questions we have to
solve in the energy and environmental
space and the best policymaking is
achieved through a lively rigorous
exchange of ideas and opinions informed
by facts and figures and findings
that's why energy week is so important
and why I couldn't be prouder of the
work that's being done here at CMU and
the Scott Institute earlier this year I
was fortunate to attend a roundtable
convened by the Scott Institute we heard
from dozens of CEOs business leaders
energy policy analysts and stakeholders
on the biggest barriers to improving
industrial energy efficiency especially
in manufacturing the Scott Institute in
my office
are now working on a report from that
event and a number of bills to address
many of the concerns that were raised to
me that's a good example of what this
week's events can produce new
information and new ideas and especially
ways we can better collaborate with
stakeholders in this region and around
the country throughout my service in
Congress I've said that good
policymaking doesn't happen in a vacuum
throughout that time I've always been
proud of what I like to call western
Pennsylvania pragmatism consequently
we're all looking forward to hearing and
learning from our speakers today and
utilizing that information in our work
in Congress so I want to thank you all
for having me here today and thank the
Scott Institute for convening what is
going to be another great event and now
while I have the great pleasure of
introducing the new kid on the block and
you know rich and I were just at the st.
Patrick's Day
parade with Governor wolf and Senator
Casey and we're all standing there and
then all of a sudden up walks Connor
lamb and all these young ladies going
Connor can we get a picture with you and
rich looked at me and he says we're old
news buddy if you just being pushed
aside and governor wolf patted him on
the shoulder and said enjoy this while
you can the honeymoon short in our
profession but I'll tell you what Connor
lamb is an impressive young man he did
something that a lot of people across
the country didn't think can be done and
he did it with a lot of hard work a
tremendous game plan this is a
born-and-bred western Pennsylvania guy
served our military in the Marines of
marine captain and a former assistant US
attorney somebody that's really grounded
I believe in western Pennsylvania
pragmatism which is what we need more
and more down in Washington DC people
that are going to be pragmatic willing
to work together to get things done I
think he's going to be a tremendous
addition to the Pennsylvania delegation
and next Thursday a week from tomorrow I
will have the privilege of introducing
him on the House floor when he gets
sworn in as the newest member of
Congress and the newest member of the
congressional delegation in Pennsylvania
it's with great pleasure that I
introduce to you
Connor lamb
[Applause]
good morning thank you all for having me
here I'm glad they're not putting up my
picture because I noticed I wore my only
tie today the same one that was in that
picture so maybe after I serve a few
terms I'll be able to get some more but
really appreciate you having me here
today as Mike mentioned before I got
into politics and before I came back
home to Pittsburgh I had the honor of a
lifetime of serving as an officer in the
US Marines and I'm still in the marine
reserves and sometimes if you haven't
served in the military people forget or
they would ask me you know why do we
have a Marine Corps when we already have
an army you know both forces seem to
serve on land they drive around in tanks
they carry rifles they do a lot of the
same things well the reason is because
the Marines are designed and trained
specifically to move very far very fast
in a moment of crisis or emergency so
after 9/11 the Marines were already out
on a ship in the middle of the Indian
Ocean and they got to Afghanistan first
you know within two or three weeks after
9/11 and they were on the ground already
penetrating that territory in a space of
time that the army could never do cuz
the Army is larger and their equipment
is heavier and they're stationed back on
land in the United States they're not
sitting out there on ships in the middle
middle of the ocean the reason I bring
this up today is because as part of our
training as part of our ongoing learning
in the way that we prepare our Marines
we're always looking for things ways to
cut the load to make us lighter make us
faster make us more efficient and
effective on the battlefield and now
secretary Jim mattis who was a general
during my time on active duty
used to talk about unleashing us from
the tether of fuel how Marines could be
so much more effective and we could do
so much more and go places faster if we
had more reliable and more efficient
sources of energy because we do have to
power the tanks we do have to power all
the incredible communications and
satellite equipment and computer
equipment that we
and that does always operate like a
tether holding us back
now unfortunately when we have a complex
engineering problem that requires a lot
of research and thought and intellect
when we have problems like that in the
energy sector
no one says send in the Marines that's
not what we're for
Marines are called jarheads and as
somebody from another service once told
me they said a lot of times the jar is
empty
but thankfully we have the Department of
Energy we have experts like you who can
solve that problem for us and put us to
work
so when I go down to Washington I will
have my eye very closely on sources of
funding for scientific research for
energy research and I hope to join a
proud tradition of elected officials
here in western Pennsylvania who have
pushed for that over many years
Congressman Mike Doyle is one of them
he's a great champion of this funding
and he's part of the reason why when you
see an initial budget proposal from the
current White House that would cut
funding for the National Science
Foundation by 30% that when they passed
the spending bill last week that funding
was actually increased and the funding
for the Office of Science within the
Department of Energy was increased by a
lot because we need it China is
investing massive amounts of money in
energy research and in artificial
intelligence and the whole wave of the
future for reason because that future is
up for grabs and I intend for you the
United States to win that race I intend
for western Pennsylvania to play a
leading role in that race and we are in
fact part of a proud tradition
congressman Doyle and I are both
preceded by congressman Jack Murtha my
fellow marine and congressman Billy coin
all Irish Americans as it turns out
probably none of us would be much use
with a circuit board or behind the
computer screen but the Irish have the
gift of gab and so we can go down to the
halls of Congress and make the best case
that you'd ever imagine for something
that we don't even ourselves understand
but that's just something the good Lord
gave us so I'm proud today to introduce
another great Irish American politician
who bridges this divide because he is
also an engineer and a graduate of yours
school as well as my high school Central
Catholic rich Fitzgerald has been such a
powerful and great and inspirational
leader for us here in Allegheny County
he has moved the ball so far down the
field in so many areas including the
development of our energy resources and
supporting great institutions like this
one so without further ado rich please
[Applause]
thanks Connor that's cuz I couldn't get
into law school so that's all
so the forum you're making me speak
between corn or lamb and Ericka
Strassburger the new kids the new
exciting kids on the block
that's okay did we count all those votes
in Washington County that you got okay
but make sure anyway it is great to be
here it is great to be again at my alma
mater who has done and continues to do
so many great things around innovation
specifically around energy but on so
many different levels Congressman Doyle
talked about the history of western
Pennsylvania and where energy is and
while that goes back over a couple of
centuries I almost feel like we are
still at the beginning of a great
technological revolution in the energy
field we know that changes are coming so
fast in the job market and jobs that
exist today may not exist tomorrow and
things like transportation but one thing
that's never going to go away and
continues to increase is our insatiable
need for energy and the changes that are
that are continuing to come around that
that energy need also are matched with
our need for sustainability our need for
our impact on the climate our need for
our impact in communities and what they
are and as congressman Doyle and and
congressman elect lamb talked about you
know there's a pragmatism about solving
problems and while politics certainly
enters into a lot of the decisions that
those of us in elected office make
science still matters
and you can't change those laws of
physics and those laws of of
thermodynamics etc that are part and
parcel of what we do so because of the
great research coming out of this
institution
you know Pittsburgh and western
Pennsylvania are on an upward trajectory
we're in a good space for folks that are
looking for jobs and economic
opportunities and it's because of what
comes out of this university that the
lot of that occurs and a lot of that
happens as Mike mentioned you know what
we're seeing around manufacturing
you know the shield production around
what's going to be happening here over
the next couple of decades and how we
can do that in a sustainable safe
environmentally friendly way as a
challenge we're all faced with and all
the choices that we have in energy from
solar and wind and nuclear to the fossil
fuels to geothermal the hydro etc are
things that will have an impact on on
how we pay for things how we produce
them how we transmit them how we store
them all those all those things that you
deal with and you give us the advice to
try to make good policies that make
sense for the region and for the
community so I I congratulate Farnum
number one on his presidency I think I
can't tell you how what a great choice
that was for not just for this great
university but for this region in
general so I want to thank you in fact
the University Board of Trustees for
having the great wisdom to make that
selection and the partnership that we
have in this community is NaN I don't
think there's any place in the country
that has that type of partnership of
working together across the governmental
spectrum at the federal state local
level our universities our business
community our labor unions our
foundations community groups all the
folks that have a stake those stake
holders get a seat at the table and we
work together we work together to solve
problems and that's what you're going to
be doing over the next couple of days as
as energy week continues so let me now
introduce another new person and that's
a great thing about Pittsburg we've got
some really new dynamic leaders who are
who are coming on the scene over the
next of the next year you met Connor and
we know it with congressman elect Liam
is going to be doing in Washington but
right here in this very district we have
another new leader
Erica Strassburger and I guess I should
say new but not so new because she's
been doing this work as the former
councilman Diane Gilman's chief of staff
for the last four years and I know the
great work she's done working with the
university working with our neighbors in
our community and what does the impact
of what happens
the national level what does that mean
to us right here in our neighborhoods
Erica is absolutely poised to have the
expertise to be able to you know
influence how that's going to affect us
she worked in the environmental
community for many years so her area of
expertise is something we can certainly
need certainly use so without further
ado let me bring up our newly elected
getting sworn in tomorrow
councilman elect err Erica Strasburg
Erica thank you rich and thank you to
CMU in the Scott Institute for having me
here today I'm thrilled to be here and
as mentioned as the council member elect
for the district you're currently
sitting in I want to offer you a warm
welcome to see any CMU's energy week and
to district 8 so collaboration you've
heard it from Farnum you've heard the
word cooperation here today here today
this morning collaboration really is a
hallmark of Carnegie Mellon I've seen it
firsthand it's an institution that truly
walks the walk on multidisciplinary
cross pollination so it should come as
no surprise that collaboration has
extended beyond the borders of this
campus to include the likes of the city
of Pittsburgh Carnegie Mellon and the
city have collaborated to to build a
smarter more energy independent city
allowing Pittsburgh to serve as an urban
test laboratory for technology
advancement energy innovation and smart
mobility using artificial intelligence
technology CMU's traffic 21 and metro 21
smart cities Institute has worked
closely with the city of Pittsburgh on
its scalable urban traffic control
project which is an amazing project that
you might have even experienced or
driven through here in the city
converting traffic signals to a system
that senses oncoming traffic and
actually changes its cycle based on the
most efficient way to move traffic
through busy intersections in the pilot
project there was an impressive 40
percent reduction in vehicle idling time
and 21 percent reduction in carbon
emissions from idling in addition CMU is
remaking cities Institute and the city
a partner to transform its standard
streetlights to LED powered streetlights
increasing energy efficiency to create
well lit communities this is the kind of
collaboration that has again allowed the
city of Pittsburgh to be the testing lab
for new technologies and just a few of
many examples throughout the decades of
this kind of partnership and as the city
and the region worked to attract new
talent and growth and investment that
the region desperately needs
I'm also very mindful of the growth the
rapid growth that's experienced that
we're experiencing just beyond these
doors in the East End neighborhoods of
Pittsburgh and we can be a model for
smart growth for the region and beyond
if we do it right
Pittsburgh has begun to invest in an
electric elite of vehicles including
charging stations that are now
operational and one of the nation's
first electric police cruisers the city
is improving the energy efficiency of
its government buildings following the
lead of CMU which in 2003 opened the
city of the nation's first residence
hall that was LEED certified and now
boasts 13 green buildings and by
investing in alternative modes of
transportation the city is encouraging
its residents to use a bicycle or public
transit or to walk instead of driving a
car
so as Pittsburgh strives to grow while
also meeting its resiliency and
sustainability goals I'm confident in
the potential for us to do so while in
close collaboration with CMU and I truly
look forward to being part of that
partnership so welcome again to energy
CMU energy week thank you again for
having me today and now I have the
distinct pleasure to welcome Anna Siskin
with the Scott Institute for energy
innovation here at CMU Anna is the
organizer of the CMU energy week 2018
and will tell you a little bit more
about the week's exciting event so
please give her a huge round of applause
for all of her work
good morning everyone so nice to see all
of you here I have a few slides I'm
doing a little bit of housekeeping this
morning but I definitely wanted to start
with a welcome welcome to CMU welcome to
energy week we're very glad to have you
I know that many of you traveled from
far and wide and we appreciate having
you here so what we have ahead of us is
pretty extraordinary I've put together a
few numbers because that's what CMU does
really well so I'll take a moment and
I'll give you a few of those as of last
night about a about a thousand attendees
have registered about 300 companies
hundreds of hours of volunteer time as
well as staff time and and those of us
putting this together
91 speakers 45 sessions
38 student posters 30 startup companies
19 investors 17 faculty members
showcasing their work 13 awesome
sponsors thank you very much to our
sponsors 12 new energy fellows that
we'll be announcing 10 student teams
competing in our competition nine panels
eight keynotes over three days so some
pretty staggering numbers but I think
the really important thing that I want
to mention before I get into the
housekeeping is really not about numbers
but it's about you it's about all of you
and each and every one of you that came
this all this way it's important to our
work to have you here to have you in
Pittsburgh at this moment I'm so the
conversations that you have I hope are
transformative to the work that you do
when you get back to your regular lives
in all those other places but I'm glad
that you've decided to invest your time
with us over the next three days so we
hope that all of your time here is
really extraordinary next slide there
are a lot of people to thank this is the
sort of working group Advisory Committee
so these are folks that I called it the
late time of night and ask questions
about panels and topics and things that
we could really work on quite a few of
these folks are actually here in the
room
right now Jeff McDaniel Bruce Gephardt
grant Irvin Bob Borzello I know you're
all here so thank you to those folks
special thanks also to our conference
and Event Services team our
communications team and our interns and
I want to shout out especially to a
couple of people who've done some
extraordinary work this is Jenny Delaney
and Michael Harding who've both put in
timeless efforts to make this work
and of course there's Amanda King who's
our communications analyst you might
have gotten one or 20 emails from her
but we are very glad to have you here an
important part of the team so the Scott
Institute you might have seen our
building if not we have tours that are
happening later this week
it's an extraordinary building about a
hundred and seven thousand square feet
and it's a place for people to come
together and it includes housing the
Scott Institute so our mission is really
to bring together those 150 faculty that
we talked about for research and
strategic partnerships public policy and
education so a few highlights of things
that you'll see this week as well as
things that are happening with the Scott
Institute again we're highlighting those
the faculty that are working in energy
already bringing them together with new
opportunities we do programming like
this it will actually be launching an
energy consortium in 2019 that's
something we'll be talking about later
this week we have competitions and we
inspire students and teams to have
innovation and entrepreneurship as a
part of their education here we want it
to be a part of their experience we do
that through the Allegheny clean tech
prize which will be on Friday as well as
the investor forum which is a new thing
we're doing tomorrow morning and then we
host academic centers and research we'll
be announcing results from our first
year of the power sector carbon index
will be launching or relaunching I
should say the Green Design Institute
that'll be on Thursday night we're
looking at pilots to do districts to do
testing a district scale and deployment
those are things that will be coming up
and we're also I'm going to be launching
an energy challenge and that will be in
2019 more
so this week in particular we have some
exceptional speakers many of you are
registered for them in to highlight in
particular this afternoon Don Anderson
will be here from Blackstone Group he's
the head of the the sustainability
director for the largest privately held
real estate trust and Praja Mori is here
she'll be our first speaker and she'll
be next this afternoon we have a
conversation between our Mayor Bill
Peduto and Mayor Harmon Yulin Cruz from
San Juan Puerto Rico a senior alumna and
we have 9 panels across those couple of
days on Thursday Dave Danielson from
breakthrough energy ventures will be
here that's bill gates operation and we
have some exciting announcements and
work that we're doing together
Randy gentry who's actually here in the
front will be giving a talk tomorrow
afternoon at 4:30
Alex Lasky from Opower which was
recently purchased by Oracle we'll be
talking about entrepreneurship tomorrow
afternoon we're doing a reception in our
newly minted LEED Gold Scott Hall
facility I mentioned already that we're
doing an investor forum but at the same
time we'll have a fair so that people
can see and touch all of the
technologies that these startups have
they've come in from a five-state region
and we'll be showcasing faculty work
that in many cases you may not have seen
before
finally on Friday morning at 10 o'clock
Andrew place will be here he's a CMU
alum and he's also the vice chairman for
the Pennsylvania PUC Chris white who is
the newly named CEO from philips
Lighting will be attending and balaji
john apathy will be here in the evening
to talk about energy and equity and
inclusivity
we'll have tours will have the allegheny
clean tech mm-hmm
uprize during the day so there'll be
activities in this room throughout the
week a special thank you to all of our
sponsors
this event would certainly not be
possible without all of their support
and if you are on social media these are
some tags that you can use CMU energy
you'll see this CMU energy come up and
a couple of different places including
in our real housekeeping so we've gone
to a digital format for asking questions
today so we have an app called slide oh
you can simply go onto your browser type
in slide Oh calm it'll ask you for an
event code and you put in pound CMU
energy and that will allow you to ask
questions during a session so it's
important to actually put the questions
in towards the beginning will be
moderating them and the moderators for
each of the panels this afternoon will
be able to see those questions as they
come in our event app is busy oh so many
of you have that already a great way to
keep up to date and connect with each
other and just a reminder to please
silence your cellphone's if you have not
done that already
so with that thank you very much for
being with us I'm glad to have you here
and I have the distinct pleasure to
introduce our interim provost Lori
weingartz
so our guest speaker Anne has come in
and I see that we're running a few
minutes early so why don't we take about
a five or ten-minute break and we'll
allow them to get back and we'll start
promptly at 11 o'clock
thank you again
you
about two minutes
all right if we can call folks back to
their seats now it's time to move on to
the next session on time
thank you but before and it's my job
again to very very briefly give an
introduction to Laurie who is then going
to be introducing our first keynote
address before that though I just wanted
to reiterate and when Anna said and
personally think Anna also for all her
work this has been you know a gigantic
effort to get all this together and I
also want to recognize Debbie Stein and
Joe he's ur who also are associate
directors at the Scott Institute and
their work is scattered throughout and
especially on Friday Debbie Big Show is
the allegheny clean tech competition
which we're extremely excited about
innovation is in the title of the Scott
Institute and this is a showcase for
innovation both regionally and within
the University and so it's a again my
distinct pleasure to not have to have
done most of what you're seeing here so
I'm just it's great to show up and be
part of this but a lot of credit goes to
the staff of the Scott Institute who are
to a person incredibly competent and
great people so one last thanks to them
and then we'll so Laurie uh weingartz is
the moderator of this coming panel she's
responsible for leading the she's the
interim provost for CMU and she's
responsible for leading all the schools
colleges and Institute's and academic
planning implementation also she's a
national Lee and internationally
recognized scholar on group processes
and social motives and tactical behavior
that affect negotiation later this
evening she'll also be the moderator for
the distinguished mayor's forum with
Mayor Carmen Cruz from Puerto Rico and
Mayor Bill Peduto from Pittsburgh and
it'll be fantastic to see how about all
that goes and so I hope that you stick
around for not only this session right
now but come back tonight to hear that
amazing interaction so without further
ado Lori
[Applause]
good morning everyone welcome to today's
energy week keynote at carnegie mellon
we're featuring our very special guest
and prema Dori we're very happy you
could join us for this third annual CMU
energy week as you know it's organized
by Carnegie Mellon's Wilton East Scott
Institute this energy week 2018 brings
to campus thought leaders as you know
from industry government academia the
nonprofit sector to engage and
collaborate on energy research trends
innovative technologies and
opportunities now I'd like to share a
little bit with you about our very
special speaker today and Premo Jory is
one of the nation's top corporate
executives in energy and utilities and a
sterling example of what women can
achieve in corporate leadership as
president and CEO of ComEd one of the
most influential electric utilities in
the state of Illinois and oversees a
delivery of electricity to 3.8 million
customers in Chicago and northern
Illinois and as a native Chicagoan
myself I'm especially interested to hear
what she has to say the next time the
power goes out for my family back home
I'll know who to call okay seriously and
join ComEd is the lead lawyer and head
of regulatory policy in the late 1990s
working on the company's transition to
competitive energy markets she rose to
become CEO in 2009 overseeing the
day-to-day operations of the electric
grid and customer operations in 2012
ComEd made her the first woman to hold
the post of president and CEO under her
leadership earlier this year
ComEd became one of the first utilities
in the nation approved to build a micro
grid cluster with that kind of impact
it's no wonder that she serves on the
board of directors for the Chicago
Federal Reserve Motorola Solutions
Babcock & Wilcox Enterprises and several
civic and community organizations
notably and took a very non-traditional
path to corporate energy success
she studied communication
in theater at the at Miami University of
Ohio before earning a law degree at
DePaul University and transitioning into
the energy sector it does make me wonder
if she has a little Carnegie Mellon DNA
in her now as we say that's so CMU and
is a perfect example of what we are
about here at Carnegie Mellon
cross-disciplinary research and
education that produces outstanding and
innovative results and we're very
pleased to have you with us here to
address us today so please join me in
welcoming and par maggiore Thank You
Laurie that was a great introduction I
appreciate it and you can call me or
your family and call me with an outage
anytime we we learn to live with that as
as utility executives were pretty much
24/7 and we take all phone calls
interestingly recently a phone call that
we took was from Puerto Rico and I you
know you're having the the mayor of San
Juan here and I think that's very
exciting we actually have crews down in
Puerto Rico now we've been down there
for several months doing work and I can
say that's been some of the most
impactful work that I think our company
has done to be able to go down there and
provide relief to those people who have
been without power for months and months
and months so a great experience and I
just share that on the note of
collaboration and the way our industry
works together David Owen is here and
part of a EEI the association of
utilities investor owned utilities
across the country and this is what we
do when there's a big event a big
disaster we come together and and
support each other and so I thought I'd
mention that but I will also talk a lot
about collaboration and working together
and how we get this energy
transformation done
but I'm delighted to be here at Carnegie
Mellon and in the city of Pittsburgh
both the institution in the city are
renowned for invention and perhaps more
importantly for their partnership in the
city's reinvention invention is hard
reinvention is harder invention takes
intelligence vision and Drive
reinvention takes all that and more with
reinvention you don't have the luxury of
starting from a blank whiteboard you're
required to build on top of and around
infrastructure that already exists
you're required to address economic
interests and renegotiate social
expectations long and deeply embedded in
an existing system it's making sure that
you don't tug on the thread that
unravels the existing system before
you've built the new one so Pittsburgh
figured out this delicate weave
Pittsburgh created a viable vision for
the future based on a clear
understanding of its past
in fact it reformed its original
construction as steel city and build a
new economy leveraging its past
industrial leadership from smoky city to
Robo burg a technology-based city poised
for the future and that evolution made a
lot of sense because it stayed true to
the area's core strengths as one
observer put it pittsburgh is a place
where stuff gets made and building its
new economy Pittsburgh to find a mission
to create a sustainable engaging city
with a commitment to 100% renewable
energy and Pittsburgh had resources in
addition to its technical past it had a
group of civic governmental academic and
business partners who came together
because they recognized that the mission
couldn't be achieved unless all
interests connected this reinvention
didn't happen by chance like every good
revolution it had a vision a mission the
technology and resources to execute on
the vision and a recognition by
stakeholders with nope local knowledge
and a systems perspective that every
piece you touch
physical economic social is
interconnected to every other piece in a
delicately balanced weave the recipe
worked the region has seen its
population grow by 40 percent since 2000
the innovation economy with Carnegie
Mellon at the epicenter is booming the
quality of life is saturated with
culture and low cost living and the city
has become a destination a few years ago
the president of Pittsburgh's Downtown
Partnership provided a great validation
of the city's rebound he said in the
city we are starting to see strollers so
in energy we are also in the midst of
reinvention frankly I prefer calling it
a revolution it's personal to me I was a
kid in the 1960s and found all the talk
of social change and revolution
intoxicating by the time I had really
grown up and could be active in anything
I found myself in the 1980s out of denim
bell-bottoms and wearing white polyester
pants we somehow had moved from civil
rights and spiritual enlightenment at
Woodstock to dirty dancing at Saturday
Night Live discos from Jimi Hendrix and
Janis Joplin to Wham and the biggest
fraud perpetrated in pop music Milli
Vanilli I have never gotten over it so
I'm claiming my revolution here right
now in the transformation of the energy
sector and you all know it's a
revolution you see it you feel it you're
part of it it's the second electric
revolution being designed to support the
developed world's third Industrial
Revolution and the revolution has all
the ingredients of Pittsburgh's
reinvention there's a vision which is to
build an energy system of six attributes
clean or lean or smarter more reliable
more resilient and more custom there's a
mission to create a system to serve a
digital economy and to make the benefits
broadly accessible to all people there
is increasingly the tools and technology
to make it happen and there can be no
question that Rita
the most complex Network machine in the
world and unraveling an economic
structure embedded in laws developed
over a hundred years requires an
alliance of stakeholders all of whom
understand that every piece we touch is
interconnected so I want to spend my
minutes with you today talking about
what the roadmap for this revolution
should look like and how we're executing
on the roadmap at comment but before we
talk about where we're going it's
important to talk about where we came
from and Pittsburgh understood this just
like Pittsburgh were not writing on a
blank whiteboard we're constructing on
top of existing infrastructure physical
economic and social I come from Chicago
and its utility Commonwealth Edison and
I'm not writing on a blank whiteboard
either in fact at the turn of the last
century Chicago and Commonwealth Edison
were the epicenter of the emerging
electric industry Chicago is where
Thomas Edison sent his top lieutenants
Sam in Seoul to find a way to sell his
light bulbs on a massive scale
but in Seoul did far more than that he
made my hometown the birthplace of the
industry's business and operating model
he invented a whole new approach to
generate distribute and finance electric
power in Seoul centralized power
generation and distribution rolling up
decentralized power providers and
systems into one entity that could
produce electricity at mass scale as
Edison said of building the early grid
it was necessary to invent everything
dynamos regulators meter switches fuses
fixtures and a host of other parts in
Seoul whoa of all these parts together
with investments in the physical grid
tied to a complete set of economic and
regulatory layers all creating a social
compact full of expectations for what
became an essential service to our
economy and quality of life eventually
in Seoul's model overwhelmed and
overhauled this industry in 2000 the US
National Academy of Engineering declared
the creation of a national electric grid
the greatest engineering achievement of
the 20th century it was the greatest
because it made most ever
other innovation possible either because
electricity is used to make it or
electricity is needed to run it the
edison insole model is remarkable for
its massive impact on the physical
economic and social aspects of 20 20th
century american life but ironically
insoles model is most notable because it
sowed the seeds of its own demise the
20th century relic is the gateway to the
20th first century economy today our
electric system has enabled the
emergence of the third Industrial
Revolution where everything is digital
billions of people and countless devices
can communicate across borders and
oceans where mobile computing is how we
live automation is part of our economic
DNA and artificial intelligence is no
longer a futuristic dream and in this
world it seems everything is electric
from the ubiquitous ecommerce technology
that undergirds our economy to the
robots of Pittsburgh to the tools of the
healthcare system to the future of
transportation and perhaps in its most
unexpected twist the new economic
revolution the model in this enabled is
calling for an energy system that is
more distributed more competitive more
akin to the one in Seoul redesigned a
hundred years ago we are going back to
the future
so the first electric revolution sowed
the seeds for what we now know is the
digital electric world that the
fertiliser for its growth emerged in
1962 yeah 1962 why 1962 I don't know how
do I know that it was in 1962 I don't
even know why I came across this but
1962 was the year with the publication
of Rachel Carson's Silent Spring
launching the environmental movement and
creating a mission for our future system
in 1962 we saw the invention of the
light-emitting diode initiating energy
efficiency technology reflecting an
industry's shift in perspective around
enabling technology and the introduction
by a group of
prescient animators of a futuristic
family illuminating an electric world
and providing a vision for the future
had I known I could have helped thank
you the 21st century transportation
space from robotics teleconferencing my
camp and supersonic schools
[Applause]
1962 the Jetsons of the Jetsons world is
no fantasy the mission of sustainability
will not be denied and the technology
tsunami started by LEDs is only gaining
force this future world is no fraud it
is no Milli Vanilli it is here and at
ComEd we take quite seriously this
vision of a future electric world not
surprisingly we believed as did
Pittsburgh that not only can this new
world be built on the existing system we
believe the existing system makes the
new electric world possible no one
disputes the energy system of the 21st
century must look very different from
its predecessor but some suggest that
the grid itself is obsolete imagining a
totally disconnected and distributed
system to this course of the
disconnected I'd simply paraphrase Mark
Twain reports of the grids death are
greatly exaggerated in a world where
every household can be its own personal
power plant where there are more
electric vehicles on the road where
power is coming from into many different
places the grid becomes more important
not less and the reason is simple it's
the power of networks
according to UC Berkeley professor carl
shapiro there is a central difference
between the old and new economies the
old industrial economy was driven by
economies of scale the new information
economy is driven by the economy of
networks the internet and wireless
networks are of course the most visible
symbols of our economic era but at its
most basic level the electric grid is
just one big network to connecting
people homes businesses schools
hospitals and virtually anyone or
anything that requires power which in
our modern economy means basically
everyone and everything put another way
a single home with its own rooftop solar
array in a basement battery is a
powerful idea but becomes far more power
if that setup is part of a network that
does what networks do enhance choice
generate efficiencies and create
opportunity so it comed we're
approaching the future in a way that
both honors the past successes of the
electric grid and allows for new uses
customers will make of it we're
designing a platform that enables us to
offer the strength and stability of the
interconnected network and the
innovation and choice that independent
markets so effectively offer like
Pittsburgh's reinvention roadmap were
focused on the physical economic and
social threads of our reinvention our
first area of focus is building a
physical infrastructure that
incorporates the sixths attributes I
mentioned earlier clean lean smart
reliable resilient and custom and the
service imperative of broad
accessibility in Illinois we've just
completed a six year modernization
program adding smart meters Smart
Switches smart sensors smart substations
all of which have combined to improve
reliability by 50% and cut save our
customers billions of dollars check
reliability we recognize that 20th
century reliability as a 21st century
cousin resilience driven by the need to
withstand challenges of a changing
climate and security environment comment
is addressing this requirement with more
underground infrastructure more
modularity in design and through new
experimental technology like
superconducting cable which will allow
us to connect multiple substations in
the Chicago Business District and lean
on the excess capacity in one substation
in a way not currently possible in the
event another substation experiences a
problem
check resiliency we address lean through
our five-year voltage optimization
program through which will fit half of
our 5,000 feeders with technology that
allows us to control voltage more
tightly and reduce system-wide energy
usage in the range we expect about 2%
check lean and our solar for all
programs set out in Illinois future
energy Jobs Act creates a path for 3,000
- solar predominantly community scale
moving toward clean and assuring the
broadest access possible and on the
attribute of custom we're working on
pricing and services tailored toward
individuals or individual customers but
our initial foray is focused on
information with pilots like personal
reliability reports and data services
like this
[Music]
[Applause]
pretty vacuum yesterday there was a
there was a power outage I couldn't
vacuum like that asked comment when was
our last outage your last outage was
over a year ago would you like me to
give you the details
[Music]
thank you check custom those are
actually our employees and Laurie next
time your folks need information on
their outages we're sending them to
Alexa reco we don't do rockets that
would not be mine so that's the work on
the physical network we also have work
to do to upgrade the economic system and
until very recently the focus of our
business had been on pushing power
through a linear pipeline of mass
production and distribution all
controlled by a single entity the
vertically integrated pipeline business
however is a relic of the 20th century
that's not how the economy functions
anymore not in the era of the smartphone
in the internet the age of eBay Facebook
uber Airbnb and more each of them
platforms networks that provide the
architecture for people to interact move
rent buy sell and work simply put
platforms are the dominant business
model of our time and if you're an
existing company and you want to survive
you can't keep singing the same old tune
you have to compose a whole new score
but the electric industry a networked
industry is well suited to a platform
economic model and if we get the digital
melodies and technological harmonies
down right our evolving electric grid
has the potential to become one of the
most important platforms in the economy
so we're exploring accomplishing this
through a four layer model that begins
with the infrastructure of today the
physical system and builds an operating
and planning function one layer up still
very much traditional utility layer
three is focused on energy transactions
starting to get away from traditional
utility topped off by a fourth layer
featuring services like energy
efficiency demand management and solar
services utilities will need to fulfill
the same core responsibilities
delivering affordable reliable power
when and where it's needed but now we're
inviting a multitude of actors sellers
and buyers of energy services and
information to interact on the grid as
well it blends the stability of the old
world with the choice and agility of the
digital age our engineers love adding
new technology to the grid and working
through fascinating economic models like
the platform fuels the enthusiasm of our
very smart economists and financial
minds but as it was in Pittsburgh
reinvention the system must at the end
of the day work for people so we're hard
at work exploring the social
implications of all this change in
parallel with the physical and economic
questions in designing the energy system
of the future there will no be no
one-size-fits-all solution like we've
had in the past the technology economics
and consumer expectations are driving to
smaller solutions within the larger
Network like community generation and
micro grids on Chicago's South Side in
the Bronzeville neighborhood we're
beginning to build a community micro
grid we're designing what may be the
nation's first small network of micro
grids as we connect the comment micro
grid to an existing micro grid at
Illinois Tech or the Illinois Institute
of Technology as it was formerly known
and integrate control technology that
will allow for dispatch across the two
micro grids and sharing and optimizing
resources in the event of outages these
micro grids play a unique technical role
in developing grid resilience but we'll
also explore the power of people
community and connection our Bronzeville
project will allow us to experiment with
the social aspect of electric
infrastructure as never before we will
be testing the concept of an electric
ecosystem of technology driven services
to support a community by adding
concepts like smart streetlights
demonstrating electric vehicle
ride-sharing is a community mobility
solution installing wind solar and
battery powered outdoor lighting units
to create safer spaces
and establishing community information
kiosks but perhaps the most important
test is the connection we make with
customers and the connection community
members can make to one another so we
will also be testing community
connection concepts through a sharing
economy program where we will afford
customers participating in our energy
efficiency programs the ability to use
their savings to reduce their bill as
they do today or to donate the savings
to a school or church or a community
organization and the social crown jewel
is the experimental trading platform we
have in the design phase to incent
energy efficiency investment we are
developing an attribute a tradable
attribute around a kilowatt hour
reduction we hope to design a trading
platform via smart contracts now I'm not
an engineer by training but I am a geek
at heart so I get really excited about
the technical aspects of micro grids but
here's why I think they're truly special
they meet us where we are they're a
solution for how more and more of us
live in 2017 and 2018 the most exciting
innovations are often happening at the
neighborhood level and micro grids allow
us to meet the unique needs of each
neighborhood and draw on the unique
strengths of local communities while
taking advantage of the overall
interconnectedness of the grid so I've
thrown a lot at you this morning
reinvention roadmaps platform models
Network economics micro grids milli
vanilli so what's the take away even as
utilities help lead the effort to
reinvent our energy system we must do so
under much tougher conditions than many
other innovators we can't simply focus
on the exciting technical aspects alone
or any other single aspects of
transformation without minding the broad
system effects some of you may be
familiar with a book that came out a
year or so ago that aptly describes how
Silicon Valley approaches innovation
it's called move fast and
things the idea that it's desirable to
radically disrupt the existing order in
pursuit of something better and that's
really exciting stuff but we don't have
the luxury of taking that approach in
this industry we can't afford to have
our electric grid breakdown today on our
way to a more promising tomorrow we are
9% of the US economy and the other 91%
relies on us so we have to run a
business the supports and enables the
activities of all others the phrase I
use to remind my team of their
obligation to look at all the
implications of the transformational
steps we take and to be mindful of which
thread you're tugging on is technology
leads but policy rules while we often
think of regulation and policy is a
hurdle and it is it also embodies the
interconnected network of economic and
social expectations and so we have to be
mindful of that and this is where you
come in my message isn't simply that we
need to understand the system we're
dismantling although we do and it isn't
simply that we need to create the
correct new policies though we do it's
also that we need everyone at the table
this is once again where Pittsburgh got
it right where the city's vision mission
and Technology converged to bring this
20th century economic powerhouse into
the 21st century through a group of
critical stakeholders of which Carnegie
Mellon was first among equals it is also
where Carnegie Mellon is getting it
right bringing together different
schools engineering policy and business
to soak on this big question of energy
information energy transformation now we
must take the same approach in
reinventing and revel I revolutionising
the energy system across the United
States so I'm honored to be working with
all of you in forging the second
electric revolution it's important it's
exciting and I can't wait to see what
comes next
thank you very much for your time
[Applause]
we have questions that are coming in so
on your tables we've dropped a note
again about our app which is slide Oh
calm so we have a couple of questions
that have come in and so I have them
here on my iPad technology at work so if
you don't mind and sure thank you again
for a wonderful presentation Thanks aha
me here the first question comes in from
Johanna and she wants to know what do
you see as their regulatory hurdles to
achieve your vision particularly with
micro grids yeah well there's many many
regulatory hurdles out there so one of
the challenges that we have is being
innovative and taking innovative steps
when you know the current regulatory
model you know really and the law really
sort of constrains what you can invest
in as an electric utility so for
instance the micro grid isn't precisely
within the four corners of the law in
terms of what were permitted to do
there's some questions about generation
ownership there's some questions we have
battery storage in there you know what
is the role of battery storage is at
generation is it distribution can the
utility own it we're a restructured
state so the question of generation
ownership is always there so it's you
know probably a twenty five million
dollar project at the end of the day and
the question is are you willing to place
that bet without knowing that you'll
actually recover those cost when you go
into the regulatory agency with your
rate case or do you want to sort of
carve a regulatory path to get some sort
of pre-approval that will very much slow
you down so this micro grid we've been
working on for about three years
we made an attempt to set up legislation
that would allow us to build micro grids
that did work so we went to the
regulator and we actually got approval
for this just in February so you know
one of the hurdles
is how do you till ''tis engage in
innovative and experimental projects
when the law is not designed to
accommodate that and you're always doing
that at risk and I think you know we
understand that we're pushing the
envelope and there's a certain amount of
risk that we're willing to take but many
of these projects are going to be quite
expensive we just have a very expensive
business the infrastructure is not cheap
and so how much risk are you willing to
take is you know is always a question
and so that's one of the ways we've
tried to solve it we one of the things
we were able to do about a year ago at
the legislature was we took energy
efficiency and rather than write it
traditionally has been a pass-through
basically if we spend a dollar on energy
efficiency we recover a dollar so it's
just a pass-through we turned it into an
earnings opportunity which in cents you
creates incentives in the utility in our
business it becomes a part of our
business so we're incentive to want to
do that the other thing we did with
energy efficiency to turn to change it
is we created a an RD bucket around
energy efficiency now it's limited
toward energy efficiency but it is you
know it is a bucket of dollars that we
have every year to spend an innovation
space but it specifically carved out in
legislation the next question we have is
how do you attract different industries
to create a unified vision for
collaboration and policy innovation what
is a shared motivation motivator well I
think the shared motivator first of all
it's not easy work and it's some of the
hardest work and I commend Carnegie
Mellon for what they're doing in terms
of bringing multiple disciplines within
the school together to focus on this and
honestly the Pittsburgh story is
phenomenal that doesn't happen every day
to bring various stakeholders together
you know create a common vision create a
roadmap accomplish the mission and
really drive something forward in that
way
so you know I think the con so it's hard
to do it takes a lot of work it takes
building trust over you know many years
amongst different people but I think you
know there has to be a shared vision of
the future and it's a shared vision that
creates broad benefits and that's how
you bring people and is that they see
benefits we're putting together a
collaboration right now around smart
cities in Chicago and there's academic
institutions there's Argonne National
Labs has developed a really you know a
neat kind of sensor that you can put out
it works on the system but it also has
environmental at you know sensing
aspects to it so we've got Argonne in
the mix there are the MacArthur
Foundation is in the mix and their focus
is very much around the human aspects of
what technology brings so I think you
you bring people together with a shared
vision that there are broad benefits and
when I look at energy transformation I
mean there is nothing I think you can
spend your time on this day today in
this current world that can have broader
impacts than energy transformation when
you think about environmental social
economic this is a business a system
that touches every aspect of our lives
quality of life and and to work on that
and ensure that the transformation
creates the broadest benefits I think is
really exciting so the next question is
is comment doing anything to work with
small and medium manufacturers to
improve their energy efficiency we are
we have some significant energy
efficiency programs for for businesses
in in our in our service territory and
you know when I talked about the energy
the energy efficiency trading platform
that we're trying that we're creating
it's in design phase so we got a lot of
work to do on it but we want to test
smart contracts and some of the
distributed ledger kind of concepts in
the business but the main focus of that
will be businesses you know because
they're going to have enough kilowatt
hour savings to make you know
reading impactful and it will also be in
their interest that you know the goal
here is to you know you got to create
some currency around the kilowatt hour
reduction in order to trade them and the
currency is we know half of the fortune
500 more than half of the fortune 500
companies have sustainability goals and
that's what customers expect and that's
what investors expect I don't know if
anybody read the Blackrock letter to to
you know their their investment
companies this year but it was very much
focused on human benefits in the
environment and then that's what you
know black rots expecting from the
companies that they invest in but so the
idea is to create some currency but the
focus will be on on small and
medium-sized businesses to sort of
create that trading platform so yeah
we're very we're very involved in that
next question and they're coming in so
we're gonna give you a few more good
what is calm adds roadmap to accommodate
the ever-increasing transportation
electrification yeah we are working on
that I would say we're you know there
are probably places and utilities around
the country that are a little bit ahead
of us on that I think California has a
lot going on with charging stations the
utilities in general have been very
focused on building charging stations
and the reason for that is the way we
make money is by building infrastructure
we put iron in the ground we go to the
regulator we pass it through a rate case
and we earn a return on it so anytime
you can put iron in the ground and your
utility it's a good thing I frankly
don't think that charging infrastructure
is where where the game is at on
electric transportation I think there's
so many more interesting questions in
you know the network aspects of it both
in terms of how does a person from
California who's driving across the
country and gets into your service
territory get charged and you know it's
almost like an ATM network how does that
work so I think that's a question that
we have to solve that's very interesting
and will require both competitive
companies and the utility and then I
think the other really interesting
question around Elektra
transportation is when you've got when
you're managing a distribution grid and
you've got generation inside the
distribution grid and it's very volatile
and you've got people buying and selling
and you're really managing a much more
dynamic grid the questions of how you
the contracts that you create with
vehicle owners how you draw on their
energy or ask them to back off and pay
them for demand management all those
questions of how you manage the system
in that in that kind of scenario a lot
of which will be automated are are
interesting questions in my mind we're
working with environmental groups in
Illinois right now to to try to look at
electric transportation and think about
how we can jumpstart that for the future
but I think we're probably a couple
steps behind some other places on that
so a good question from a university
what kind of skills are you looking for
in your future employees yeah that's a
great question so we definitely need
technical skills obviously there's a lot
of technology here but we need people
who can combine that with you know sort
of creative thinking skills I mean you
almost want a little bit of liberal arts
and a little bit of Technology you know
blend it in I need people who can be
agile and nimble who can think about you
know playing a role on one team one day
and then you know a couple months later
shifting to another team and playing a
different kind of role and so people who
know how to be collaborators and
followers and leaders when needed people
who can be technical but also can be you
know creative and see the you know human
and you know community side of things as
well and the impacts of their technology
so it's really interdisciplinary and
again you know I give you know Laurie
and Carnegie Mellon a lot of credit for
you know looking at this question cross
functionally because that's the way
we're trying to solve it I'm actually at
a conversation with Laurie earlier today
about inside the company
utilities a really really hierarchical
and they're very structured very
linearly so you have your engineering
Lane and you have your economists and
you have your lawyers and you have your
finance people and they haven't
traditionally talked much to each other
and so I'm throwing them all into the
same room and telling them that they got
to figure this out together
and it's very interesting it's very
interesting but I need people who can
talk across different functions and can
kind of work in those kind of teams
because a team I am together today in a
couple months it'll be a different team
some of them will be the same but I'll
throw some new people in there so this
ability to kind of shape-shift and morph
and evolve and you know play different
roles is is is is a big piece of what
the future will require I think in our
companies we always need good engineers
with the law limiting your business in
some ways
how can startups engage with you are you
able to invest in innovative startups
yeah so I'll come at that question a
couple different ways one is so we're
part of a larger holding company exelon
exelon has five utilities and in a very
large generation company and so there's
exelon actually which has more of a
competitive side as well as a regulated
side actually does invest in in in
start-up companies so that usually that
comes through the exelon realm not so
much the regulated utility realm but
here's how I think we we think about
engaging with startups and third-party
companies I talked about the platform
model in the four layers that we've kind
of you know identified that we're trying
to work through and when I talked about
it I talked about the first layer being
really the infrastructure layer that's
kind of where we live today and that's
probably where I think the utility lives
for a long time in the future planning
and operating similarly I think you know
you probably want your utility to do
that when you get to layer 3 and you
start thinking about energy transactions
and you get to layer 4 and you start
thinking about services transactions
then I think you start to bring in third
parties because that's not especially in
a restructured state like Illinois we
run wires and poles we don't run
generation we're not going to be
involved in most of those transactions
it's queer going to facilitate them as a
platform kind of an eBay we connect
buyers and sellers but we're not the
buyer or the seller for the most part
and so I think that's how we think about
bringing in the innovation that small
companies that startups that new you
know fresh views of the industry can
bring as well as sort of maintaining the
stability and and doing what we do best
we have a marketplace right now it's
basically an internet marketplace but
it's a little bit of an experiment that
we're doing we've had it up maybe a year
and a half now we've got smart
thermostats that we sell on it again
it's not we don't make smart thermostats
but nest does and others do ecobee and
so we sell those smart thermostats
across the marketplace we're evolving
the marketplace we expect to see solar
start to emerge in numbers probably
fourth quarter this year and we're
putting together a solar services
platform so if you're thinking about
purchasing solar you can come onto our
platform we'll pull down your usage
we'll take a google shot of your home
we'll give you the economics of running
solar off of your home if that's not
feasible we can give you the economics
of a share and a community solar program
and where you might find that similarly
once you make the investment in solar
we'll have a tracker that allows you to
track the economics the payback etc so
this is you know sort of the the
services platform again some of which I
think we can provide because we can do
that efficiently and some of which will
have third parties brought in and that's
how I think will connect at the utility
level the next question how can
universities help utilities the most to
advance innovation beyond research
well I we have I think you know part
partnerships and partnering in you know
very specific projects you know
obviously the research that comes out of
universities are tremendously helpful
and we you know rely on that quite a bit
and watch that I think that you know
coming in and being part of specific you
know projects and really helping to make
this work on the ground is I think sort
of a next phase of engagement where I
think there's lots of opportunity to
more questions is that okay sure okay as
long as you - tail so what made you want
to work in the utility industry we're
getting personal um so I practice an
antitrust lawyer for about ten years and
I got a call from a headhunter about the
time that the restructuring law was
passed in Illinois late 90s and what the
restructuring law in Illinois did was
was one of the first states to
restructure as they pulled generation
away from the transmission and
distribution network set him up
separates ultimately separate
subsidiaries and the company was looking
for lawyers who understood markets
because they didn't have anybody or
monopoly for a hundred years they didn't
have anybody really internally who
understood markets and the legal
entanglements of regulation and you know
when I got the headhunter call I liked
practicing antitrust law I thought it
was great but I thought this is really
the last sort of fully economically
regulated industry obviously regulation
hits most industries in many different
ways but fully economically regulated
industry this was the last one to go
through restructuring you know Airlines
had gone telecommunications trucking and
and and you know you got you're sitting
here with the electric industry and
you're left with it and I thought it's
just a great opportunity you know for an
intellectual challenge and I never ever
thought I'd end up here I just thought I
was going to have a great time
practicing law in this
realm of untangling you know a
hundred-year network of regulation in a
way that would allow markets to work and
provide benefits you know to consumers
at the end of the day so that's why I
jumped alright so the last question what
is your strategy for handling the data
coming from new technologies and what
role do you see machine learning
techniques playing for tackling Grid
problems yeah I think so yeah data is a
is a huge question that is really you
know sort of underlies everything here
and there's a lot of work to be done
there so on the one hand we need data we
need to figure out how we use data for
operational purposes there is so much
opportunity to more be more efficient
operationally I mean we literally still
do you know our maintenance you know you
know time base maintenance every couple
weeks we send somebody to the substation
to you know check the gasses on the
transformer and you know to be able to
do condition based maintenance the the
amount of cost that will pull out of our
system is tremendous so that's you know
one lane of using data in in our
operations I think you know automation
and you know intelligence and robotics
also has you know tremendous benefits I
saw recently robotics that's used on we
use drones to fly our transmission lines
but I saw a robot that essentially you
know runs along transmission lines and
detects you know faults and when you
think about being able to do your
inspections and maintenance by virtue of
technology you know not only are you
going to run a better and more reliable
system but you're going to take cost out
so there's a big piece of data in
running our system that we have not
figured out we have just scratched the
surface and we need an awful lot of help
because it's just not our bailiwick
the second area is the data that you
need to animate markets and there's
always a push and pull there there are
you know third parties who tend to want
more of the information than we want to
give we're a little concerned because
obviously security interests in this
industry are significant and and so
we're very careful about what kind of
data gets out there about you know
system configuration and that sort of
thing so there's a big push pull on that
and I think that will continue for some
time and you know we'll find the right
balance but we are cognizant of the fact
that we're going to have to share more
and that it's important to have it out
there in order to animate markets create
benefits for for consumers and then I'd
say the third bucket is really data
privacy and and you know maintaining
that and that is very parallel to what
we see in other commercial entities and
and trying to make sure that we've got
the right practices as well as
technology to protect that but Tom this
is a huge area it's an area where again
it's not particularly our you know our
strong suit and I think there's a lot of
room for for help on that okay thank you
I just want to take a moment to thank
him for all these her wonderful
insightful comments her breadth of
knowledge and her ability to translate
it in a way to get us off thinking
deeply was very notable and inspiring to
me so thank you very much in so we run a
tight ship around here and we are now
going to exit a little bit early for
lunch but I want to tell you about how
this is going to work before I do that
again one more round of applause for and
progeny more so you all are currently in
rangos 1 & 2 so on the other side of
that wall is rangos 3 for the duration
of the meeting over the next few days
that's where food is coffee and drinks
are there throughout the day but right
now what we're gonna do is exit through
these two doors and in a calm and
orderly way make our way into the next
room there are actually three buffets
there double-sided so grab some food get
yourself a drink at the ends and then
bring it back here we'll have social
time networking time until our next
session starts which will be promptly at
12:45 restrooms are located across the
hall and if you have any other needs
please stop by the registration